I know the genesis of this film was you
know it's something that took several
times and several journeys so let's
start with a little bit of that I mean
you know I guess the idea was a dinosaur
and his boy yeah in 2009 Bob Peterson
the returned director pitched that idea
I had worked with him on up he was a
writer and co-director that and a mentor
of mine and um soon after he had pitched
that idea he asked me to come to help
develop that concept strictly about the
boy and dog and flipping it making the
boy the dinosaur and the dog the human
boy and we were developed that for
several years you know I mean it got
very complicated it was like a boy and
dog story and then it became a
father-son story and then it became
about trying to change a community and
there were other little story lines in
there mixed in well and so after three
years or you know two years ago they
asked me to take over and then and then
Denise came on and Meg was there as well
and then we would kind of simplify the
story back to Bob's original heart of
that boy and dog story we essentially
just stopped the production which I
don't think has ever been done at Pixar
and just started literally started over
and scrapped the sets we replaced the
voice cast because we needed younger
characters we which this was extremely
difficult replaced the department a lot
of the department heads because one of
the things that I felt was really
important is that you know Pete needed
to be supported with experienced
department heads if he was we wanted him
to solely focus on the story meg and and
the story team really needed to get this
to work very quickly so we went on
pretty rigorous screening schedule right
where we screened the movie literally
every six weeks was your editor the same
editor throughout or did you change
editors so yeah I mean yeah I mean the
original version of the film had a lot
of first-time supervisors including the
editor so I brought on an editor that I
had worked with and who was extremely
experienced and I knew we had to work
fast so that was again one of the
choices that we made and it was you know
I used I like to say I use
a lot of goodwill currency doing that
because unlike you know live-action we
see people day in and day out were there
on staff so it's not like people
disappear right but ultimately I felt
that that was the right thing to do for
the film and for Pete it was very much
planned from the beginning not just
because of the speed we had to go but
also because of the story that Pete was
seeing that it would be very little
dialogue and be an immersive film so the
story team and Kelsey and I and Pete we
all and Denise we all watched black
stallion together we all watched never
cry wolf together we watched a lot of
immersive films who watched a lot of oil
and dog films of course but at this
point we were watching a lot of
immersive films to see how how do you do
that how do you immerse the audience so
deeply in a place in a setting and then
with two characters or characters that
you're just happy and thrilled to watch
their behavior together so we did a lot
of that and then it really came down to
a lot to the storyboard artists because
they were the first ones in and after
the script you know I'm laying down the
stone so to speak you know I'm laying
down the spine and the stones and kind
of the emotional through line to make
sure the relationship will hold it needs
to hold on the page and all the logic
and so there's a lot of construction on
the page but then it has to go into
boards where really it has to come alive
because they're not talking so there's
you know they're doing the acting in
pictures and if it can work in boards we
knew it would only get amazing 100,000
times better once it was animated this
was also an animators dream to
ultimately work on this film and just it
was really remarkable to watch because
we had to work so fast you know Megan
the story team would kind of you know
put down the ideas and then the
animators would just plus it in a way
that was quite remarkable you know and
this is where Jeff and Michael really
come into play so much with this film
Pete and I knew that the music and the
sound design would be so incredibly
important to telling the emotional story
of our characters and it's really
fascinating because
a lot of comments have been that people
don't feel like it is there's a lot much
or is less dialogue as we we keep saying
and I think that's because the music and
the sound design does so such an
incredible job helping us with the story
I understand the idea of a lyricist and
a composer I don't know that I
understand how two composers work you
know I don't know obviously I suppose
the fact that your brothers helps that
you grew up and have kind of an
understanding of each other but how do
you compose together and do you divide
up the work or do you bounce things off
of each other what's the process well I
think we think of each other in a way as
an extension of ourself and we've been
working together so long obviously we
have careers separate from each other
but we go back as kids playing music
together so it's something that's just
absolutely second nature to us and and
we're very similar obviously we come
from the same place we listen to the
same music growing up our parents saying
and we heard also all of us have you
know there's so much unspoken already
that's already connecting us in that way
but we have different strengths and I
think when we first saw this film there
was such a opportunity for for a lot of
the strum stringed instruments that Jeff
plays he's got this incredible
collection of and he can tell you all
the names of them but bazoo keys and and
sizes and things from all over the world
that we wanted to honor the the kind of
folk
Western nature of it but not get too
cliche so we wanted to do that in an
interesting way right up Jeff's alley
and then I I'm more of a piano player
and so I played the kind of Grandma's
porch piano that you hear in there
sometimes and so I think for this movie
it just was something that that was
perfect for our collaboration and how
actually how we work is we you know we
just do it organically we'll say okay we
we knew that this film needed to be very
melodic and have strong melodies and
that's the thing we spent a lot of
time on that that's where two of us
working together really was a
strengthening thing that much like Arlo
and spot help each other their journey
that to lift their game you know one of
us would write for bars and then the
other one might finish it or he might
write the whole melody and the other one
go it's great but this note here you
know and I think it could be stronger
here and it just it's it's just kind of
a constant polishing and you get two
guys looking at it and standing back and
making it better it just gets better and
it really yeah lifts it to a level where
you know that it's it's beyond what
either of us could have done on our own
when we first looked at the film it's
it's a magnificent canvas for music I
mean I incredible to look at it's a
beautiful world they've created and then
there's not a lot of talking in some
scenes sequences there's just a lot of
space so we thought you know there's a
lot of different sort of levels of
storytelling going on here and you know
you move in and out of the Western thing
into the primitive world into some stuff
there's very deep emotional things and
the music has to track that whole
journey but still stay cohesive so we
knew there had to be an orchestral bed
that we built you know into right into
the foundation of this score but then we
wanted to heavily pepper it with these
other elements were maybe a bit
different so to honor the the natural
world we use a lot of pre-columbian
instruments some very primitive crazy
and stuff very kind of unmusical but we
would make it work somehow with the
orchestra like mike has said that there
was strum e instruments and stringed
instruments that we were able to use for
the western things and we didn't really
present that exactly normally so to
speak I mean like a lot of the things
that people think of banjos are actually
these Turkish guitars this thing called
a June Bush and it's all just a little
off a little left because they're not
really Cowboys they're dinosaurs so
homesteading dinosaurs frontier yes